beautiful day to enjoy all of those
activities
so that's all the good news but i think
today at the press conference
expect some dose of realism and caution
from the prime minister he's very aware
that this needs to be a staged uh
unlocking
and he's very concerned that people
might just let their hair down
a bit too much and relax their guard so
i think the message
uh today will be from the prime minister
to remain cautious he will remind us
that cases are
still rising across europe and that the
variance of cavid and we've seen a
number of them haven't we over
recent weeks can all threaten the
rollout and the success
of the vaccine so just trying to get us
all to keep a lid on it if you like
and unlock slowly good news though
on the vaccine over 30 million adults
have now been vaccinated
or at least had the fast jab about seven
percent of the adult population with the
second jab
as well that's over 30 million people 57
of the population with their first dose
of
uh the vaccine and um we're going to
have the briefing as well in the new
year okay
okay beth i'm going to interrupt you
because we're going over to boris
johnson
in his new media room with the first
chance to see the outdoors
where there are six people or two
households and i want to congratulate
the members of
ilkeston cycling club in derbyshire that
set off at midnight
the swimmers who broached the chilly
waters of the hillingdon lido at the
crack of dawn
and more than anything i know how much
it will have meant
to millions of people to join someone
else
for a cup of tea in the garden and i
must stress
that it's only because of months of
sacrifice and effort
that we can take this small step towards
freedom
today and we must proceed with caution
it's it's great to see that yesterday we
recorded
the lowest number of new infections for
six months
deaths and hospital admissions across
the uk
are continuing to fall but
that wave is still rising across the
channel and
it's inevitable as we advance on this
road map
that there will be more infections and
unavoidably
more hospitalizations and sadly more
deaths
so what we need to do is to continue
flat out
to build the immunity of our population
build our defenses against that wave
when it comes and now that we've
vaccinated more than 30 million
adults across the united kingdom
it's more vital than ever that we
protect the most vulnerable
the evidence seems pretty clear that
vaccinating the elderly and vulnerable
has helped to drive
down rates of hospitalization and death
and now we want to reinforce that
prediction
with a second dose so for many people
april will be the second dose month
please take up your appointment when
it's your turn
and at the same time as we push forwards
with our program
to offer a vaccination to all adults
by the end of july we're building up
our own long-term uk manufacturing
capabilities i i've already told you
that novavax a potentially significant
new weapon in our armory against kovid
is going to be made at fujifilm
in the in the northeast and i can today
announce that
the vaccine task force has reached an
agreement with glaxosmithkline
to finish and bottle this precious fluid
also in the northeast giving us between
50 and 60 million doses
of uk max made vaccine subject to the
right approvals
from the mhra and then of course
there is one other way we can all build
our own
individual defenses against covid
and enjoy ourselves at the same time and
that is to take
more exercise and so i'm personally
thrilled that i will be able
uh to play tennis for instance and
without being remotely preachy
i do hope that we can take advantage of
this moment and the beautiful weather to
play sport
to take exercise to have fun and build
our national resilience in that way too
and remember that outdoors is generally
much safer
than indoors and the way to continue
on our cautious but irreversible road
map to freedom
is to follow the rules and remember
hands face space
and fresh air thanks very much i'm now
going to
hand over to chris for the slides thank
you prime minister
first slide please so the first slide
shows the pattern since september of the
number of people
testing positive for covid in the uk and
as you can see this has dropped a long
way
from the peak in january although it is
now flattening out and i'll come on to
why that is in a minute next slide
please
fortunately the number of people in
hospital in with covid
in the uk is continuing to fall and
as you can see this is now down to much
lower levels
than it was last month and the month
before that
next slide please and
the uh the best news really on this is
that the number of deaths
of people who had a positive test for
covid in the uk
is continuing to fall and the most
recent
seven day average is 63 deaths
next slide please and this is partly
due to lockdown and a large part of this
is due to lockdown
but also partly and increasingly due to
the vaccine rollout
and this slide shows the steady increase
in the blue bars of people who've had
their first
dose of vaccine and in the orange at the
bottom
those who are having their second dose
of the vaccine and as the prime minister
says
the number of people having a second
dose is going to increase
significantly over the next month and it
is essential that people do come for
their second dose
next slide please
i thought we would show we should show
two slides
really just to uh put a little bit of uh
detail
on this and the first of these uh is to
compare the age distribution
of people who sadly have died from covid
on the left
and what you have is the ages steadily
going up from
0 to 4 at the bottom up to 90 at the top
and the red line is the point at which
vaccination has reached so it's reached
down to
those who are 50 and above plus people
who got pre-existing health conditions
the final cases have been found and i
really want to stress that anybody
who in that group in those 50 or above
who has not been called for a
vaccination
should make contact with their doctor
but and this is an important but the on
the right what we have is the total
number of people
who have actually uh acquired kovid
and as you can see on that the great
majority
of people who have acquired kovid are
actually younger than this
so the majority of transmission is in
younger age
groups who have not yet been vaccinated
unless people have got pre-existing
health conditions
or a health or social care worker or
care for someone who is vulnerable
so um we therefore anticipate
that as uh there is gradual unlocking
in the way the prime minister has
described it is
inevitable that there will be some
increase
in the number of cases because the
people who are most likely to catch
and to transmit kovid are in that
younger
unvaccinated group so the vaccination
has had a really big impact
on helping to protect against people
dying from covid although it is not a
complete protection
but it will have less impact on
transmission because of this age
distribution next slide please
the second uh new point i really just
wanted to make and then sir patrick is
going to make a point uh about vaccines
uh is to say that the bit of the
road map opening up that has happened so
far
is opening up schools and what you can
see on this and i think this is likely
to become
clearer over the next uh two weeks
is that there has been a steady decrease
in the rates of covid over the last
several weeks in most age groups but
there's been a flattening and possibly
even a slight uptick
in transmission amongst people our
children of school age this isn't a
dramatic increase
at this point but this is inevitable
that as
bits of society open up there will be
some increases in transmission and we
should expect that that is uh
one of the things we have to anticipate
will happen as some
opening ups occur so patrick just wanted
to make in some additional points on the
vaccine
thank you have the next slide please
so a few points about vaccine if you
look at the left hand
part of this figure in the blue
this is giving an illustration based on
the
current and recent rates of infection
across the community roughly how many
people
you'd expect to be in hospital or to be
hospitalized
over a four-week period so if you take
the top age group in the 25 to 34
age group out of a hundred thousand
people
in the population of that age over a
four week period
roughly seven people would expect to be
hospital you'd expect to be hospitalized
if you go to the next age group 35 to 44
so you took 100 000 people in the
community
over a month four week period you'd
expect
roughly 14 people 45 to 54
21 people and 55 to 64
29 people if you went to higher ages of
course you get even more so this just
reinforces the point that as people get
older the risk of hospitalization
from infection is greater now if you
look at the right hand side
this tells you what would happen if all
of those people
were vaccinated so if everybody were
vaccinated and this is taking a single
dose
so it's giving roughly an 80 percent
protection
you'd find that in the youngest age
group there 25 to 34 instead of there
being seven people hospitalized
over a month it would be one or maybe
two
35 to 44 instead of it being 14 it would
be
two three as you go to the higher ages
45 to 54
instead of 21 it would be four
and at the highest age group on this 55
to 64 it would be roughly six people
instead of the
29 so there are three points i want to
make first is the one that
as you get older there's a higher risk
from this disease as chris has also
shown
the second is that the vaccines are very
effective
at reducing hospitalization in everyone
who gets them
and so the message is everybody who's
asked to come forward for a vaccine
please get the vaccine but the third
message
is that the vaccines are not 100
protective
and this is at the current rates of
infection
if the rates were much higher then
obviously the amount of hospitalization
would be higher
which reinforces the point that the
thing that we all must do is try and
keep rates down and be sensible
as we unlock and get back to more
interaction
thank you thanks very much patrick thank
you chris let's go to
beatrice from london
with restrictions easing people are
slowly being reunited with their
families
for those with family abroad they have
not been able to see them for months
will a similar easing take place for
those with family abroad
or will seeing family be incorporated as
an exception to international travel
like the exception to travel for
business purposes
beatrice thanks very much i think that
the the most important thing that we've
got to do
right now as we uh continue to immunize
uh great numbers of people in this
country is protect our country
insofar as we can it's never going to be
perfect
but do as much as we can to prevent the
virus coming back in from abroad and new
variants
uh coming in from abroad so the rules
about uh what
you can do what people can do to see
their families abroad will be governed
entirely
uh by the rules that uh cover uh
travel abroad and uh people coming from
abroad so
uh at the moment as you know uh it's
still uh forbidden to
to travel uh we'll be saying uh a bit
more on april the fifth
about what the global travel task force
has
has come up with and um
clearly at the moment it is you know
there are
lots of countries that are on a red list
35 countries
on a red list where we have very
stringent uh measures in place
uh for them for people arriving from
those countries have to go immediately
into hotel quarantine and if you're
coming from anywhere else
uh you also face a pretty tough
quarantine rules so
um we will be beatrice we will be saying
more
about um uh seeing family
abroad and and travel abroad but it
won't be until
at least april the 5th any any anybody
want to
say any more on that thanks beatrice
let's go to julia from margate
uh julia asks myself and my husband have
had our first dose of the pfizer vaccine
and are due to have our second dose at
the end of april will this be impacted
by the recent shortage
of supplies and what does the government
plan to do about it well julia i think i
can answer that question very
uh briefly and uh succinctly by saying
that uh
that there isn't any need to worry about
a shortage of uh fisa for the second
dose
as far as we can uh see at the moment
and
uh we're going to continue to uh to roll
that out and
and supply that and as i said april is
going to be the
the second dose month uh very important
everybody gets there uh their second
dose
uh hugh pittman from bbc
thank you very much prime minister isn't
there a danger of mixed messaging
when you talk both about a road map to
freedom and getting back towards normal
life but also the need to be cautious
because of cases rising in some parts of
europe
and a question for professor witty and
sir patrick
valance how concerned are you about
what's happening in some european
countries with cases and what that might
mean for the uk and have you given your
approval to the next stage of easing on
april the 12th
the opening of outdoor hospitality and
non-essential retail and so on
well thanks very much hugh and you're
absolutely right that the
uh we're pleased to be able to
uh to have some measure of uh of
relaxation
today it is important it is valuable and
i know it will be prized by
uh by people but also very important to
stress that we are continuing to be
uh cautious and uh the whole point about
the
uh the road map and the time scale that
we've got it gives us a chance to
evaluate the uh the data as we go
forward and uh as for the
uh for the april the the 12th uh phase
we'll be we'll be saying more about that
in in due course obviously
same goes for may the 17th uh june the
21st
they all depend on on the four on the
full conditions but i i wonder whether
uh crystal patrick you want to say more
yes sorry
patrick um well i think when we
discussed the
gap between stages the idea was to have
five weeks to allow
data to be assessed in the fourth week
which is the earliest we think we can
get a good handle
on what's happened and so that's next
week so that's when the analysis of
the effects of the initial opening of
going back to school
can be assessed and at that point we'll
be able to give the recommendations
so far as chris is laid out everything's
moving in the right direction but we
need to do a formal data analysis next
week
in terms of the are we concerned about
what's happening in europe and elsewhere
well i mean in those
you know anybody would be concerned
about any country in the world where
rates are going up because
that has a big impact on people's health
and lives so i think you know as
as citizens of the world we will all be
concerned about any
of those countries for the uk there are
essentially there are two risks there's
always a higher risk
if any country's got a higher rate than
you have then there is a risk of net
importation of
kovid but the much bigger risk and the
one that we're all concerned about is
the risk of variance of concern these
are
uh covered variants which might and i
want to stress the word might
have a a problem with the vaccine where
it would the vaccine is less effective
against them
and so the main thing we're concerned
about is the risk of importing
into the uk variants which could have a
reduced
effectiveness of the vaccines we're
currently using now
in the long term there would be ways
around that but in the short term that
is the principle the thing that's
driving
concerns about border issues at this
stage uh in terms of giving approval uh
it's not really for
uh sir patrick or me to give approval of
things but certainly we've been involved
heavily in all the decisions
uh in terms of even giving technical
advice to ministers
thanks very much you called in itv
thank you prime minister uh there's a
great sense of
release around the country today with
the lifting of some restrictions
do you worry at all that uh people might
take that
too far and what sort of word of warning
would you give people who are attempted
that way
and for professor witte um you showed us
a graph of
how uh the reopening of schools more
fully created a bit of an uptick
do you worry at all that uh today's
relaxations could also eventually cause
a bit of an uptick in the numbers of
cases and how well
at this point do you think we are
protected
by the vaccination program as a country
carl yes you're absolutely right to put
the emphasis on
on caution the vaccine rollout has been
very
impressive and you know thanks to
everybody who's been involved in it
but what we what we don't know is
exactly how
strong our fortifications now are how
robust our
uh defenses are against an
another wave and we've seen what what's
been happening that's why i stress
what's happening with our european
friends because uh historically at least
uh there's been a time lag and then
we've had a
a wave ourselves and that's why you know
i just stress the importance of
everybody
maintaining the uh the the discipline
that people have shown for so long
and continuing with the the cautious uh
but we hope
irreversible uh roadmap that were that
we've set out
um in terms of the question you asked uh
me um
uh yes there is a high likelihood that
there will be some
uptick as a result of the relaxations
today
and that was anticipated right from the
beginning of trying to lay out
where the road map would go and if you
think about the the
graph for the graph that i showed what
it shows is that the
high proportion of those who will both
catch and transmit kovude
have not been vaccinated yet and
so i would not anticipate that uh
vaccination will reduce
transmission between people in those
ages at all at this point in time but
and this is the big but
the point the prime minister was making
that has been stressed repeatedly
is that if people stick to social
distancing rules and they're
outside the risk of transmission is
massively lower
than if they are very close together and
inside
so provided people are sensible about
these and people throughout the entire
covid
uh pandemic in the uk have really been
very sensible
incredibly uh sort of
respectful of sticking to the rules and
guidelines
provided people stick to outdoors and at
a distance if it's people
who are not in their households the
impact on in terms of an uptick
should be modest but i think it would
not be realistic to think
there will be no impact and that is
something we are we're all aware of
the only thing just to add is it's
important to remember as vaccination
rolls out
that once you've been vaccinated it
takes three weeks or so before you get
some protection from the vaccine it's
very important to recognize that even
when vaccination is not an
instant thing it takes a time for the
immunity to
to accrue brilliant thanks beth rugby's
kind news
thank you prime minister you've asked a
lot of the british people over the past
year and now
even as that vaccination program's
rolled out and cases are now their
lowest level since last october
you are still hugely restricted in our
personal lives
and our liberties do you accept that you
are testing
the patience of the public and are you
concerned that people will
stop listening and to professor whitty
with over 30 million adults now having
received a
jab you've said another covered surge
would be met with a wall of vaccinated
people
with that in mind are we really at risk
of a third wave the sort we're seeing in
continental europe
or can the british people finally begin
to relax and just quickly to sir patrick
when will the doses those 50 to 60
million doses that the prime minister
just talked about of the novovax
uh vaccine when would they be available
not for me i don't think uh let me let
me go
uh straight back to you beth on that
that point about you know asking a lot
of people
and yes of course i i accept that and
i know how much government has asked of
of the
people in the last year but i also know
how magnificently
with what incredible uh patience and
fortitude people have
responded and it's my view beth that
overwhelmingly people are determined
to continue uh to to do that and they
they do understand
the need for for caution uh i think
overwhelmingly people understand
uh that uh when it comes to this road
map the more we the better we stick to
it the more
the more cautious we are the better the
chance we have of
making sure that it is indeed
irreversible and we're able to
to go forward in the in the way that we
want in terms of the question
you asked to me what is
what patrick's uh slide i think showed
is that
we do have a kind of a wall of
vaccination that will get stronger with
the second vaccines and i want to repeat
my emphasis
it is critical people get their second
vaccine but it is not a complete wall
it's a kind of leaky wall and therefore
there will always be some people who
either
have chosen not to be vaccinated or
where the vaccine has had much less
effect and if we get a small surge
there will be cases of people who have
been vaccinated who will have
uh severe disease and there'll be cases
of people even who are not vaccinated
much higher proportion who will get
severe disease and some of those will go
on to die if we get a very big
wave that would obviously lead to a
significant impact so that's the reason
why the prime minister and ministers
have been
absolutely uh determined
that this is a slow and steady uh
unlocking
looking at data between each step
because what we're trying we're except
we accept that
with this highly transmissible virus of
course
there will be an increase in
transmission as we unlock
vaccines will help hem it in as we go
down the ages
but it's going to take a while before
we've got the full protection and even
when we have
there will be some upsurge the key thing
is to keep that rate down
and to make sure as many people as
possible are vaccinated in particular
the most vulnerable
and keeping the rate down also stops the
likelihood of more
variants emerging so it's important we
keep on top of this
um the nova vast question about is an
operational one about when that's live
and i can't answer that for you but what
i will say is that um
noblevax hasn't been through the
regulatory process yet so it would need
to do that as well before anyone can
really
be sure exactly when that would come
what i can say is that they are
are already making it at the uh uh the
site in
indeed side they're they're already
making the backs of pending the
uh the mhra approvals jason groves
daily mail
thank you uh professor whitty if
someone's had
both vaccine shots as many people now
have
why shouldn't they hug their
grandchildren this easter are they not
now as safe as they're going to be for
their foreseeable future and
prime minister you mentioned uh the
encouraging signs on
some of the graphs the death rate now is
round about where it was uh when we
unlocked indoor socializing last year if
it was
good enough to do that last year why
isn't it good enough to do that this
year
uh do you want to do hugging first who's
doing i'll i'll i'll take uh
take that on um the thing to understand
with vaccines is they provide
increasing levels of protection as we go
through
the first vaccine provides a high degree
of protection
the second vaccine for the same person
provides greater protection but there's
still some vulnerability this is the
point that
patrick's slide was making then actually
having
people around someone who has been
vaccinated
who are themselves vaccinated provides a
further level of protection
and then keeping the key thing is
keeping the rates right down
makes it very unlikely that someone who
comes in even if they have have been
vaccinated certain
so even if they haven't been vaccinated
certainly if they have uh
we'll actually have covert and be able
to pass it on but what we're trying to
do is get to the point where
all of those protections are in place
and we are not yet at that stage we're
getting there
steadily the extraordinary rollout by
the nhs i think is
really remarkable and that is going
through at a real pace
but the great majority of people have
not yet had their second vaccine
and if they're meeting people who are
under the age of 50
they will not have had their vaccination
unless they actually have a pre-existing
health condition
or are a healthcare worker i would like
to
re-stress a point that patrick made
also which is that people are not
immediately protected when they're
vaccinated
and i think it is important people to
remember that there is a period of time
uh of uh if you're an older citizen
maybe three weeks or so between the time
that you get vaccinated and the time
when the protection kicks in
it will be good protection but it won't
be absolutely complete protection
i think that's an incredibly important
point for everybody to to remember
right now and jason i think the answer
is to your question it's really
contained in some of the slides that we
saw earlier where you
already because of the uh the relaxation
that we've seen
almost certainly because of the uh the
opening of of schools again you're
starting to see
some of those uh graphs starting to curl
a bit like old british rail sandwiches
uh moving upwards um uh a little bit
in the in the younger groups uh and you
you've seen what's happening in the
uh uh on the continent uh we and we've
seen that
uh happen before that's why it's it's so
vital that
you know we do what we're doing right
now we we continue to
to fortify the the population roll out
the uh the vaccine the
the speed that we uh that we are uh
make sure as as chris and patrick say
everybody gets the
the second dose when they're uh they're
asked uh
to uh to come forward uh when they're
given their turn
uh but um you know just make sure that
we
uh are cautious in our approach i think
that's the
the way to get the results that we that
we want
let's go now to jasmine cameron chileshi
of the ft
thank you the sport and tourism minister
said earlier this morning that police
will be able to intervene and fine
any law breakers where necessary but how
realistic
is that will police officers be going
around breaking up groups of more than
six outside
do you think that would be appropriate
and are you confident that the rules are
clear enough to facilitate a consistent
and fair approach to policing across the
country and secondly
as the number of coronavirus infections
grows throughout europe
why have countries like france not yet
been added to the red list
and what is your response prime minister
to concerns that throughout the pandemic
the uk has been slow to secure our
borders from cases coming in from abroad
thank you thanks very much jasmine on
the
first point about uh the policing the
police has done an absolute outstanding
job throughout this
uh pandemic and i think they've handed
out uh about
70 000 fines at least for various
breaches of one kind
or another and i make no you know i make
no apology uh
for for that uh they will continue to
uh to do their best but it depends
more than uh it depends on the piece
depends on uh general
public understanding of what we've all
got to do and that
in a way has been even more impressive
that's been the single thing that's made
all this
uh all this possible on uh the uh
imports of of new variants from abroad
and uh our border regime we have one of
the toughest regimes in the
in the world some some european
countries jasmine don't even have
uh many european countries don't even
have the hotel quarantine of the kind
that we have in the
in the uk and there are 35 countries
already on the
on the red list uh we're looking uh very
closely at what's going on in in france
we keep it under
under constant uh review of course those
i've explained
uh to people before there is the issue
uh that our
uh our trade uh in medicines and food
uh does depend uh very much on those on
those short straights so we have to make
sure that we manage
the disruption as well uh thank you very
much jasmine let's go to uh sapphire
slay of the evening standard
thank you prime minister you said that
you want this unlocking to be
irreversible can you categorically rule
out
another full lockdown and my second
question is for professor chris witte
an evening standard story today revealed
that care home staff in london are the
least
likely to take up the vaccine the lowest
take-up in the whole country is in
lambeth where just 45
of staff working in homes for the
elderly have taken it up
are you shocked by that figure and do
you think that level offers enough
protection for residents
well uh sophia i think the answer to
your your excellent question is
uh is yes but with you know two
at least two very important provisos uh
uh
yes if everybody obviously continues to
uh obey the guidance with sufficient
uh caution and we continue to work
together uh to keep the
the the virus under control and get it
done in the way that we have
uh and yes if the uh the vaccine
uh roll out uh continues and the
vaccines continue to be
as effective as it looks as though
uh they uh could be or looks as though
they are
a sapphire so those are the uh the
two conditions that would have to be uh
to be satisfied but
you know i'm i'm i'm i'm hopeful
i think that we're i don't see anything
in the data
right now uh that would cause us to
to deviate uh from the from the road map
um but you know we've got to remain
humble
in the face of of nature and we've got
to be prepared to do whatever it takes
to protect the british public which has
been our
our approach throughout um
on the question uh to me um the great
majority actually of care home staff
nationally uh have um had the vaccine
and as have an even greater proportion
of our health
care staff i think for those who don't i
i think there are probably
three things it's really important to
stress
i mean the first thing is this vaccine
will protect you and your family
and i think it is important that people
really understand that this is
uh of it's important for everyone but
it's important for the individual who
has the vaccine
themselves and those around them there's
now evidence that
if you have a vaccine as a health or
social care worker it's likely that that
is going to protect
uh provide protection to your family
second thing
uh is that there is um unfortunately
some uh misinformation about vaccines
and the key thing
is to go to reliable sources if you're
hearing
stories about vaccines and you're
concerned about them go to reliable
sources
talk to medical staff who can actually
lay out the facts because the you know
compared to the risk of
covid the risk of the vaccines is much
smaller and that's the whole point about
all drugs and all vaccines is you're
doing it because the risk of
actually not being vaccinated is
substantially greater than the risk of
being vaccinated
and the third point specifically on on
care staff
certainly uh uh when we're talking about
medical or nursing staff
i've said before and i will say very uh
unambiguously
uh i do consider people who are looking
after vulnerable
other people who are very vulnerable do
have a risk professional responsibility
to get vaccinated and to do other things
that help protect
uh the people who they're looking after
it's not just an issue about vaccination
this is across the board
vaccination is one of those issues and
so it is important that people
view it both for themselves for their
families uh but also
uh take their professional
responsibilities seriously
brilliant i think that's anything you
have padre thank you all very much see
you next time
the prime minister there saying it was a
big day for many of us
uh he said the new freedoms people are
enjoying from
today are the result of sacrifices made
over recent months but he said a third
wave was still rising across the channel
and it was inevitable there would be
more infections
more hospitalizations and also sadly he
said more deaths
chris whittie on that said his big
concern
was the risk of covet variants being
imported which
may cause limited effectiveness he said
with some
vaccines and patrick valance was making
the case that they're still waiting
to finalize the data from schools
opening
and he said that that data analysis
on the opening of schools would be
available next week uh political editor
beth rigby
is in westminster so beth a new backdrop
uh to these things uh um
so what did you make of what he said i
mean the emphasis very much was on
caution
yeah firstly about the backdrop that is
the new briefing room uh that has been
built
in recent months it's a bit like the
white house uh have a big press briefing
room where
uh the press spokesperson for the
president gives
updates we've now got one of our own
it's in nine down in
street it cost 2.6 million
and that was our first viewing of what
it actually looks like now at some point
all of us
are going to actually get in the room
when we can again meet face-to-face
for briefings and we expect that the
prime minister's new official
spokesperson
uh that's allegra stratton uh will start
giving briefings in that room
uh a number of times a week we expect
that to happen
from mid-may perhaps onwards so that's
what that new backdrop
was in case you were wondering on the
substance of what
the three gentlemen today were talking
about it absolutely was
about being on track but asking people
to keep their guard up and remain
cautious and you saw
professor witte stressing with that
slide
where he showed that while death rates
are dropping and very low
amongst those who are not under 50 the
non-vaccinated
adult population that transmission is
still
high relatively in those uh groups of
people
so the watch word really was yes we're
on lock-in
uh please follow the guidance don't pop
into your mum and dads don't go inside
for a cup of tea
stay in the garden and and keep our
guard up really was the message from the
prime minister there
when i asked professor witte
realistically could we relax a bit
given that uh we have now over half of
the adult population over 30 million
people
being jabbed does that mean that we can
relax a bit and not worry
too much about the prospect of a third
wave hitting azad it is
hitting the continental europe he talked
about uh
the wall of vaccinated people still
being a leaky wall
that it was going to take time uh to
build up
uh the vaccination that many more people
obviously
under 50 still needed vaccinating that's
millions more of us
and just to sort of go cautiously that
was the message today
uh good news though from uh sir patrick
there where he said that nothing
in the current data gave him any pause
for thought in terms of the
unlocking programme that we have so
today
just to remind you you can meet outside
with a group of six people or two
households can meet you can go and play
golf you can go swimming
in an outdoor pool you can go and have a
game of tennis
or you can have a game of football if
you want so these
things at once were normal life now such
precious gifts aren't they but you can
go and do
all of that today the next big moment of
course
april the 12th where outdoor hospitality
will reopen
and then the other thing that the prime
minister was asked about again
was foreign travel look by the end of
july
all of the adult population will have
had a jab according to the government's
plan but still no certainty on whether
that means we get to jump on a plane
and go abroad that uh update on the
travel plans and and the plans for
summer holidays
the prime minister asking everyone again
to wait for a few more days we'll get an
update
on that on easter monday on april the
5th
right and he also mentioned beth these i
think it was 50 to 60 million
uh vaccine doses being made in the uk
still got to go through the regulators
but are being uh
partly made i think at glasgow uh
glaxosmithkline yeah
at a facility in the north at barnard
castle
which has appeared obviously before in
this uh we all know well now don't we
yes yes so that so so that was that was
a new piece of news 50 to 60
million uh doses being produced in the
uk as you said
uh up at barnard castle uh just in terms
of that i did ask sir patrick
when would they actually come on stream
you know that is a lot of
uh doses of vaccine and he said uh that
particular novovax
it still has to go through regulatory
approval interestingly the prime
minister then jumped in didn't he
to stress that it was already under
production and be
being bottled up look this is all very
important because volume
of vaccine doses is really important not
just
to vaccinate our own population but as
you can see and the prime minister
has repeatedly stressed this is a global
issue there's no point in well there is
a point
but if you're all vaccinated but there's
still
high levels of cavity transmitting in
other nations across
other societies that increases the risk
of mutant variations and we saw with the
kent variant
how damaging that can be we've got the
south african variant the brazilian
variant so it really is a global effort
to try and
get as many people around the world
vaccinated so
the big question i guess as well is how
much vaccine will the uk begin to
share with european neighbours and other
countries
once our vaccination program has been
rolled out or will the prime minister
choose to begin to share some vaccine
doses before everyone's
been vaccinated yeah that's a decision
yet to be made thanks very much